what to use the most beautiful aspect
of the human genome don't get me started
so we got time um the first answer is
that the beauty of genomes transcends
humanity so it's not just about the
human genome
genomes in general are amazingly
beautiful and again i'm obviously biased
so
in my view uh the way that i like to
introduce the human genome and the way
that i'd like to introduce genomics to
my class is by telling them you know
we're not the inventors of the first
digital computer we are the descendants
of the first digital computer basically
life is digital
and that's absolutely beautiful about
life the fact that
at every replication step you don't lose
any information because that information
is digital
if it was analog it was just protein
concentrations
you'd lose it after a few generations it
would just dissolve away
and that's what the ancients didn't
understand about inheritance
the first person to understand digital
inheritance was uh
mendel of course and his theory in fact
stayed in a bookshelf for like 50 years
while darwin was
getting famous about natural selection
but the missing component was this
digital inheritance
the mechanism of evolution that mendel
had discovered
so that aspect in my view is the most
beautiful aspect but it transcends all
of life
and can you elaborate maybe the
inheritance part
what was the what was the key thing that
the ancients didn't understand
so the very theory of inheritance uh
as discrete units you know throughout
the life
of mendel and well after he's writing
people thought that
his p experiments were just a little
fluke that they were just
you know a little exception that would
normally not even apply
to humans that basically what they saw
is this continuum of eye color
this continuum of skin color this
continuum of hair color this continuum
of height
and all of these continuums did not fit
with the discrete
type of inheritance that mendo was
describing but what's unique about
genomics and what's unique about the
genome is really that there are
two copies and that you get a
combination of these
but for every trait there are dozens of
contributing variables
and it was only ronald fisher in the
20th century
that basically recognized that
even five mendelian traits would add up
to a continuum-like inheritance pattern
and he you know wrote a series of papers
that still are very relevant today
about sort of this mendelian inheritance
of continuum
like traits and i think that that was
the missing step
in inheritance so well before the
discovery of the structure of dna which
is again another amazingly beautiful
aspect
the double helix what i like to call the
most noble molecule
of our time is uh you know holds within
it the secret of that discrete
inheritance
but the conceptualization of discrete
you know
elements is something that precedes that
so even though it's discrete
when it uh materializes itself
into the actual traits that we see it
can be continuous it can
basically arbitrarily rich and complex
so if you have five
genes that contribute to human height
and there aren't five there's a thousand
if there's only five genes and you
inherit some combination of them
and everyone makes you two inches taller
or two inches shorter
it'll look like a continuum trade a
continuous trade
but instead of five there are thousands
and every one of them contributes to
less than one millimeter we change in
height more during the day
than each of these genetic variants
contributes
so by the evening you're shorter than
you were you woke up with
isn't it weird then that we're not more
different than we are
why are we all so similar if there's so
much possibility
to be different yeah so so there are
selective advantages
to being medium if you're extremely tall
or extremely short
you run into selective disadvantages so
you have trouble breathing you have
trouble running you have trouble sitting
if you're too tall
if you're too short you might i don't
know have other selective pressures are
acting against that
if you look at natural history of human
population there's actually selection
for height
in northern europe and selection against
height in southern europe
so there might actually be advantages to
actually being
not not super tall and if you look
across the entire human population
you know for many many traits there's a
lot of push towards the middle
balancing selection is you know the
usual term
for selection that sort of seeks to not
be extreme
and to sort of have a combination of
alleles
that sort of you know keep recombining
and if you look at
you know mate selection super super tall
people
will not tend to sort of marry super
super tall people very often you see
these couples that are
kind of compensating for each other and
the best predictor of the kids age
is very often just take the average of
the two parents and then
adjust for sex and boom you get it it's
extremely heritable
you